this is a production of Cornell
University dr. crows are on here today
obviously has done a lot of research on
PG ours and growth so Frank will get a
little bit of intro we're at the growing
season hear from you it's questions
answered and big thanks to Bill for
taking the time to join us this is uh
it's a real treat something that we
don't get to talk about very often
mostly because I didn't think you know a
lot of guys were using PG ours it
certainly at the school district level
it didn't seem like they were using
picked PG ours but we I think since
we've been focusing on sports turf Carl
we're really getting guys that are
specializing you know sports management
much like golf course superintendents
have been working to bring
professionalism you know historically
you know green keepers were we're Bill
Murray and guys who are now professional
like Dan Tschida Ballmer Greg Chalmers
all the people we have their
professional sports turf managers you
know it's a separate and distinct
profession and I think when you manage
it at a high level you have a lot of
tools available a lot of times at the
school district level unfortunately
because the restrictions you don't have
the same number a tool so with that no
further ado here we are again trying to
support each other through these
difficult times so again thank you all
for joining me and Carl let me get to my
thing
so again I can't say enough right as a
responsible member of the Cornell of
Cornell University Cornell Cooperative
Extension any professional educational
organization my first responsibility to
you is to make sure your keep it safe
and that I'm reminding you of it right
this is a time when we're all asked to
sacrifice a lot for the value of human
life right where a lot of us are being
told to lock down so that the weakest
among us can continue to survive but at
the same time we've got to take care of
ourselves and it doesn't appear that
this virus discriminates and and now
that we're hearing more stories of
people that have got it it's not
something everybody wants to go through
so new information as of yesterday 1:30
in the afternoon
the governor indicated that horticulture
is no longer deemed an essential
business unless you're in the nursery
greenhouse business selling food
producing plants this is New York State
for those of us that are talking to
talking outside of New York State let me
encourage you to get some clarity on
this issue because with all the
confusion around having clarity on can I
work and then the question is what
should you do right or what is essential
if you have to do things or can do
things so right now in New York State by
definition most of the people probably
listen to this can't work in the
horticulture business as we would
describe landscape horticulture to a
certain extent now at the same time
people are enjoying our landscapes as
much as they ever have in fact the parks
are now happy to really get in there and
say hey we know you're all out here but
you know you got to keep your distance
and I took this off of Ben Palmer
Ben I stole a couple of things if you're
with us I stole a couple of things from
your Twitter account I just love
following you
real good professional approach to what
you're doing put signs up if you got
sports fields that that activity is
banned then put up the sign say you you
can't you can't have group activities
here apologize for the poor quality that
I pulled off a Twitter but the idea of
signage is really important and I think
you see it in the STM a communication to
you guys as a profession the STM a is
you know hey what are the things you got
to do
well Ben they also said hey this is
weird I got a spray off the stuff that
you know showing up and happens to be a
picture of a plant growth regulator good
thinking Ben so you know how do you deal
with this internally with these
processes that you've never given a
second thought to that's what's required
to keep yourself safe right now we have
an opportunity where we're not all
geared up yet you know we're not all Gil
every no it's mowing like crazy
this shouldn't be a crazy amount of
stuff going on yet now's the time to
plan for when there are things
do and you got one person to do because
that person can go and do them as
society starts to loosen up we we may be
weeks from that and so now planning is
critical and I'll just reiterate to this
group again how much I love this
publication as a starting point that's
just a starting point right where you
look at your crew how do I keep safe
because now in the golfcourse arena
we're starting to get crews that are
getting infected so let me I'll get to
that in a second I think I got it right
here sorry I had two slides one one drop
out of order they got of course
superintendent's Association of America
GCS a has a has a pandemic resource for
golf that outlines what happens if
somebody on your crew is is that's
positive and they're doing this
obviously because you know golf is still
allowed for about seventy five percent
of America and these people are going in
and doing essential work I don't know if
they're governed under the New York
State rule that you can't work in
horticulture which means golf courses
have to be let go which means people can
play but you're not going to manage them
there's a lot of confusion but for you
as a manager if somebody on your crew
test positive if you're someone is still
going to work there is something deemed
essential in that operation these kinds
of responses and information sorry are
enormous ly critical now I want to get
the bill right away so let me just say
again you know this is one of the things
we'd be doing in the spring you know if
no play then focus on preventing
vegetation if you can work or
communicate the people what the startup
time right if we're not gonna be able to
work for the next three weeks let's say
this is for real you can't go in and cut
three four weeks right you better start
thinking about what am I going to tell
people how long it's gonna take me to
get this field in shape and of course in
some cases this is a place where a
synthetic field is likely to get ramped
up more quickly right than a natural
grass field if it's not regularly
maintained so lots of things to consider
there here's that message where are we
soil temperatures are still relatively
cool but progressing right that we're
getting into the low 50s in the
New York City metropolitan area we're
still in the 30s and 40s throughout much
of New York State and you see throughout
much of the New York the New England
region continuing to see cool soil
temperatures temperature departures are
still indicating slightly above normal
throughout much of the Northeast unless
you're to the west end of the region out
in Pittsburgh and out towards the Great
Lakes there was some warm air that's
been leaking up that way but there isn't
a big growth surge expected this week
forecasts for the week moving forward
this has been updated a little bit to
show some progression but in general we
shouldn't see much progression of the
growing season over the next several
days now Jimmy Simpson the current SDM a
president and certified sports field
manager in the town of Kerry I thought
it took a bold step he in his
president's message he said it's okay to
let things go five small things that may
make walking away from our fields a
little easier I'd say this is a good
place to start and does a really good
job of introducing our topic with bill
today about plant growth regulators now
I know bill twitches a little bit when
we put this up there because it is not
necessarily as precise as we'd like it
to be I think for people that don't give
a second thought to how grass grows it's
not a bad starting point
Bill's going to give us a lot more
information about this as we talk
forward but a lot of what we're going to
talk about is going to be related to hi
to cut and we're going to recommend his
blog that again has been primarily set
up for the Gulf guys but has really good
information there about mowing height
and height of cut stuff and I'll just
give him an intro you know I had the
pleasure working with Bill for so many
years when he was here doing his PhD and
it was literally the time off he took he
took time off to teach me something to
go back and then do the screen keeper
app blog and I think what we're going to
talk about today bill is growth rate the
grass type and how high to cut and
mowing at the one-third rule or what I'm
trying to get mow 30 something that's
simple for people to remember if you can
work here
how it's gonna go so let's I'm gonna
without any further ado I'm gonna stop
sharing my screen so we can see you
and then if and and Carl we can give
bill the screen if he wants to show some
slides bill but I just say first off you
know what are you hearing from sports
turf managers in Nebraska are people
asking you these questions because
obviously maybe your work rules are
different than ours here in New York so
let's start with what guys are thinking
about in Nebraska right now yeah
one thing I'm noticing is this morning
we have our par 3 golf course that we
take care of with the city of Lincoln
and my students take care of it so we
had to get out there because like you
said golf is a you know for us as
landscape has been deemed as part of
that essential maintenance so we're ok
here in Nebraska and our golf courses
are packed
you know we pushed you know they has a
person on every tee box last yesterday
on our par-3 course the 18 hole courses
are full people are walking through
parks for having these same issues where
you know sports fields on campus are
being used even though they're not being
maintained and shouldn't being used and
so it's really a you know people are in
this what should we be doing what's
essential and even for us I mean we're
hit talking with our students this
morning and about maintenance of the
golf course and if we're still doing a
hundred and fifty people a day on a par
three course the maintenance standards
are still you know we're not going to
the bare minimalists because we need a
crew and me a par three course we have a
crew of two full-time and a couple of
part-time students that help out you
know two so it's easy for us to do
social distancing and continue to do
maintenance but you really wonder you
know what's the level of acceptable
minimalism honestly and so instead of
saying just stop doing everything the
the concept we're promoting is let's
just do things that have to be done
waiting to be done and not just do
things to do things right and so that's
kind of what we're seeing I'll say this
it's gonna get colder this week and we
have a you know system coming through
freezing rain tomorrow but we were
mid-70s last few days and then looks
like low 80s coming here in the center
country next week some more rain so the
salt temperatures are getting 50 when we
see 50 I see tall fescue bluegrass start
really breaking and we start to see
growth really starting to push now so
it's gonna be this make-or-break time of
now I have to start acting and our
sports they're people that normally
would be pushing right now we're kind of
wondering how do I prevent that normal
spring push they would like during
normal spring baseball when there's
nothing going on and and so I think
that's kind of where we are in Nebraska
as things are really ramping up and
maintenance is needing to happen so how
do that push that back that's right so
so you're right first off in the golf
world we're saying listen if golf's
allowed its then it's what do you have
to do right and again if you get an A+
on your crew and you haven't broken up
into teams now you're really behind the
eight ball because you may have one
person yeah you may have two people if
anybody can can get out there so yeah
there's that scenario of about trying to
keep up with what you're doing and the
other part is people are gonna go on
these fields putting up signs would be
important to do for the focused activity
listen people just want to walk around
on these fields maybe three people kick
in the ball here and they're randomly
not in particular areas you know that
may still happen that does beg the
question how much will that will the
turf handle before you really got to get
growth going to keep up with it so
there's that question but where we are
here we're right maybe a week behind you
we're not gonna be anywhere near 80s up
here in the Northeast and but our soil
temperatures are creeping into the 50s
so the first thing I heard you say is
your tall fescue is going to get going
right out of the gate a lot of us have
tall fescue fields blue Kentucky
bluegrass fields probably over seated
with rye so one of the things you got in
get in sports is you oftentimes have
this you know Heinz 57 and we control it
a little bit in golf because we mow the
crap out of it all the time we're not
we're not always playing around with the
different growth rates because we mow so
frequently but in sports and when we
raise the height now we could see the
different growth rates so can you
Oh through number one when would you
start thinking about triggering it if
somebody said to you listen you can get
out to your fields one more time in the
next week or you can go out once a week
what's the trigger to start and where
would you start
yeah I think as you said you know having
as mowing based on what the growth rate
is and not just mowing to hit well I
know three times a week especially
earlier in the season when we just may
not do a need to we did research for
five years on tall fescue and we had
some buffalo grass because nebraska
buffalo grass research right but we did
those two species and looking at
different mowing heights and frequencies
and you know mowing to that one third
rule or the 30 percent removal Omo 30
that produced the the best quality of
turf with the fewest number of mowings
and so if you really do need to back
things off keeping track of that and so
there's two ways that we can slow our
growth rates down to reduce our moment
one is you mow higher so that it takes
longer to hit that mowing threshold and
then the other side is what can you do
to actually slow growth rate down
so we mow high over normal mowing yet
you know inch and a half and you have to
mow at two inches if you mow at two
inches now you get to three inches and
so if the growth rate is the same you
know the regardless of its mowing at an
inch or three inches it's gonna take
more days hit that threshold so that's
the one approach and then from another
approach just to slow it down and that's
how do we use PG R's how do we limit our
spring fertility you know can we let
things be dry if it or not you know not
add water to the system let's get
natural rainfall which you know in the
spring generally isn't a problem for
most places with soil water limitations
but those are the two approaches that we
can take to try to minimize that mowing
so that we don't have to have that crew
there so we do have a situation where
you lost some part of your crew maybe
one person could you know keep up with
the general mowing so that we don't have
to mow it up to four inches and then try
to scalp back down once everything
starts to get back to normal so and and
so your point
raising the height of cut is critical
because what I'm thinking about in the
back of my mind in all the years and I
know you know it especially true with
tall fescue I would assume there's this
phase it goes into where I don't want to
say it's exponential cuz everybody's
getting a sense now what exponential
means right watching a curve go up but
we we get a greater surge of growth in
the early spring there's a soil
temperature that typically occurs you've
got some pretty good data on what you've
seen on tall fescue let's focus on tall
fescue and Kentucky bluegrass that that
makes it a little bit easier to talk
let's say I got a field I normally keep
at 2 inches right I know I'm going to
grow more than 1/10 of an inch a day in
springtime just by normal mineralization
of nitrogen right so in anticipation of
that growth surge I want to wait right I
think I want to let my normal 2 inch
feel go to 3 inch and then mow it when
it gets to 4 and a half do you like
those specific increments as mowing
height focus to reduce growth rate yeah
definitely and you know we we found in
our mowing is that actually mowing not
scalping actually causes the grass to
grow faster so don't take that approach
the routine mowing puts a little bit of
a plant we think it's a herb every
response type of a thing and so the
plant senses the damage through some of
the things that we studied together at
Cornell about you know how to
recognition receptors actually scents
for my being munched on by a cow or by a
mower or by an insect to turn on defense
pathways and that results in a growth
rate slowing down and so by mowing to
the 1/3 rule or more frequent we are
naturally going to suppress our growth
rate by about 20% maybe 30% would be
kind of be my eyeball number without
actually running the math right now but
so I'm getting a slowdown just fine
knowing routinely but then if you
started mowing more than the third rule
so like just weekly or or the quarter
rule so you're removing a quarter of the
leaf at one mowing instead of a third of
the leaf then we're doing unnecessary
mowings yes the quality was better and
we all know that told me more fields
three to three times a week because it
looked better but if we're trying to
diss minimalize things you know we're
still gonna have you know healthy grass
with fewest number of mowings at the
one-third rule and going that higher
height gives us a longer time interval
to hit that number just for some
perspective in areas will receive freeze
and thaw cycles I pulled some research
that was done in in Prairie soils so
just thing and which is similar to a
grass you know you have a lot of organic
matter healthy soils that we're trying
to maintain if you eivol some of their
research results and interpolate how
much fertilizer was released during the
winter it can be in the soil with a lot
of organic matter about a pound of
fertilizer per thousand so imagine going
out there in the winter and putting down
a pound of N and that's why we see this
huge bursts of growth and this is why we
say don't fertilize late in November
because if you're getting a half pound
of November and half and even if half of
that stays in the soil my god what an
accord pounds of fertilizer there for
the plant and as soon as that soils hit
about 50 degrees so for tall fescue and
bluegrass the number that I've kind of
been monitoring honestly for 10 years is
that when the soil said about 55 degrees
we start to see really rapid regrowth so
it seems like that's when those plants
really started breaking dormancy and
starting to grow for rye grass and
annual bluegrass and poet Rev we see a
little earlier maybe in the mid 40s and
so we're seeing the rye grass right here
and the trim and the bluegrass really
starting to green up and the top fescue
is kind of a dog the bank grass is
really a dog and the bluegrass is
depending on the cultivar can vary some
of the old blue grasses will bring out
like the annual bluegrass some of the
new bluegrass is for low mow the lawns
that don't make much GA they need to get
a lot warmer so they're almost like a
bank grass in which they like it really
warm for them to really kind of get gone
and and I don't want to complicate this
cuz it can get complicated really fast u
s-- aster golf course superintendent
look at the green keeper after you got
three hundred and some-odd models in
protecting mowing height and type of
grass and region PGR rae all these
things that factor in two things one is
when you mow higher one
these guys are Malo more frequently as
it increases density and theoretically
should leave the greater traffic column
certainly Venini some of the guys at
michigan state showed that many many
years ago that's you know but but that's
foreplay so first what you said earlier
don't don't always do things you've
always done because it's you know not
the way not the way it's always been
when you mow higher you you get a
thinning in the stand as well phil right
you get this thinning of the stand you
get fewer plants and i want to talk a
little bit about bringing it back to
play how hard let's say you're gonna let
it go you're not gonna be able to mow
for two weeks right now it's probably
four or five inches you go back there
you would say get set the mower as high
as you can and just try to bring it down
if you can work a day cut it at four and
then cut it at three and a half and then
cut it at three is that what you
recommend I notice it's crazy because
we're not even getting into the growth
regulator thing it's more what you can
do to manage it to keep it under wraps
here because it might not be sense to
put a PGR now tell me about letting it
go up and come down as you've studied it
well this is one of those things from
the five years of doing this what we
notice is early in the season the
scalping isn't as severe because the
grass no it doesn't become accustom so
that a higher mowing height it's really
when you're maintaining it I'd say four
inches for a long period of time that
there's enough shading down your the
crown that a lot of those green leaves
are gone so then when you scalp BAM it
goes away and so that's you know one of
the bigger concerns so this would be a
really temporary thing where they said
you can't mow and you couldn't get out
there for two weeks and they said okay
well I guess you have to mow a little
bit if you know maybe violating the
one-third rule slightly isn't going to
be as bad and we see homeowners do this
all the time and so I I'm a little more
confident in that because you'll see
homeowners go six inches and then more
to two and a half inches and and you
know sometimes it looks okay but if
you're doing it all the time that's when
we're seeing these long-term differences
and so it depends on the time scale you
it was if it's been months of mowing at
even four inches and now you're trying
to get back to inch-and-a-quarter for
fall sports then yeah taking that
approach Aki what if we're fighting
green if raining it down incrementally
would be the way to go just so that that
plant can start making green foliage
down in the canopy so you're gonna mow
it shorter let some more light down in
the canopy the plan will respond by
making new leaves to fill those voids
and so that's one way we can do it and
then you know another thing about that
too is transitioning into the PG ours
the PG ours will help to sustain that
density so for to worry about that
natural lower canopy thinning we can use
the PG ARS to help us keep that density
higher during this period and again not
to make it complicated but in your work
you actually found some Kentucky
bluegrass s you don't think produce
gibberellins because you can't get
growth regulators that blocked your
brilliance to work on them so honestly
you know we did models for for a grass
fields and fairways and they look they
work really well we've done it apply
this in tall fescue and have no problems
and these are both faster growing
species if we and we go to common blue
grasses no problem you put the PG ARS
down you see a very repeatable type of
pattern if you notice the field older
fields you go to these newer cultivars
though and it just doesn't we don't see
your response and sometimes we even see
a little stimulation and growth rate
from some of the PG ours it's it's wild
and at first you question yourself like
what did I do wrong
but then when you have different labs
find the same results on different newer
cultivars with then you start to build
trust like we're doing everything right
here and we're still seeing this
response it wasn't a one-time thing
and so so it comes to these really low
slow growing blue grasses we don't
always see a response if you think about
it makes sense and turns out on the
other kind of a pest if you are gonna go
spray for snow mold in July you know
you're probably gonna have minimal type
of a response there's no mold because
it's not conducive weather for that
pathogen to grow so if you have blue
grass that
make gibberellin the hormone that is
inhibited by these Fiji ours and that's
why they gross those because gibberellin
causes the grass to grow vertically if
it's not making gibberellin and you put
something down to inhibit it
what are you inhibiting nothing and so
you don't see a response and so that's
been kind of the issue we've been seeing
with some of these products is you know
you might see a marginal minimalist
response and then you go to a variety
that produces like a Kentucky 31 tall
fescue or older blue grasses that grow
really vigorously that means that they
produce a lot of the hormone gibberellin
therefore they are much more sensitive
to these PG ours and we'll see a lot
more reduction in the growth rate okay
so I've got a tall fescue Kentucky
bluegrass sports field that I normally
keep at 2 inches in the northeastern
United States and let's imagine I've
caught it it's it's heading into that
sort of active period of growth maybe in
the next two to three weeks do you have
a particular growth regulator I showed a
picture of Ben's use of 10x that the
plant growth regulator it's the knockoff
primo it's the generic primo do you have
a particular growth regulator that you
like for higher cut turf golf cool
season turf into two-inch range and then
we can get into the growing degree day
thing let's start with the product that
you like and the work what your work
shows yeah so I've tested them all if
you can males do a screen share here
quick and I can just show you a table of
the different PGI's we've tested so you
seeing this full screen now yeah all
right so you got primo on this side on
the right
you got no primo on that side this is a
older mix of you know probably at this
point this was made like 2006 or 2007
the stand was probably seated in the
late 90s and so we can see the
difference in color and density that is
there from applying primo at point to
fluid ounces and so we definitely see
that shrunken sunken growth result and
so if I look at the dark agreed to
darker green yeah and so you know Pam
Seurat has shown that right Pam has
shown late season primo sometimes has
led to that darkening as well right bill
well and that's the thing that we will
see that alter so if you stay on your
programs right away or in state all the
way to the end of the growing season and
I don't like applying at the end of the
year when the grass has actually stopped
growing but if you continue to spray
your PG our program all the way until a
grass growth rate stops you will see
that the improvement of turf quality and
density and color over winter if you get
snow cover like in Nebraska we don't get
frequent snow cover our grass our leaves
die all the way to the crown it doesn't
make a difference all the grass is brown
but like when I lived in New York and
Wisconsin Great Lakes regions with snow
cover when the snow cover is gone you
will so notice it I remember we even
sold out on our bank grass greens and
sold out was like what did you do to
these greens already and it was like
nothing it was residual from the past
year and so this is kind of result you
can get when you don't have too much
grill suppression and so that's kind of
an idea there of what this looks like
he's another picture of it where you can
see the dark green on the left and then
the control on the right and you can get
an idea what kind of benefits so primo
is something you can spray it is burned
through your growing degree day model
again and for folks that aren't paying
attention to PG RS and what we're
talking about these products are either
processed in the planter processed in
the soil and bills figured out from
collecting clippings for 27 years of his
life how they respond and has been able
to you know determine what these
intervals are and ways of keeping growth
suppressed by following that so that's
just an entry point and primo is the one
I think you started studying but now
it's studied all of them huh yeah so if
I go here real quick you can kind of see
just our different trends and this is on
bluegrass and we'll see you know this is
a new so we put down the the Primo at
day 0 & 1
notice this constant suppression and in
rebound and so we're trying to maintain
this what are this suppression where the
dots are below this dash line that means
the grass is growing slower that is that
one line is everything below that line
is growing at a slower rate relative to
untreated nope so the theoretical if you
didn't put down a PG are it would be
growing at this line of one so we wanted
to do was apply the PG are frequently
enough and so we want to do was reapply
somewhere around here so a miss product
for a new and bluegrass this would be a
field height bluegrass at 15 ounces per
acre it'd be around 400 growing degree
days if we go past that then the grass
starts to grow faster rate and so we
want to reapply here to maintain that
suppression and you'll notice that we
have a low rate of a new versus a high
rate of a new and we just get a little
bit better a little more suppression at
the high rate but the reallocation
interval doesn't really change and so
with the PG ARS the application rate
impacts the amount of suppression or air
temperature impacts how long these
products last so that's the real
take-home point but then you have
products like this hey what do you do
you put the on Cutlass on these blue
grass fairways or fields and there's and
there's every point is after that or
maybe even slightly above level the
control and we've seen this over and
over and over multiple sites so that's
been an odd one for us same thing with
trim it low rated trim it 16 ounces they
see much had they go to 32 ounces an
acre and then I saw a lot of suppression
so just keeping those ideas there and so
we get this table so you trim it just by
that before you summarize here you like
trim it for a heavy regulation and trim
it also gives a lot of guys that can't
spray the ability to sling some granules
if this is a strategy they're going to
need in a month from now yeah and so if
you look at this table we have the low
rate for fields to the high rate for
each PGR so you got a primo trimmer
Cutlass and you can get an idea and
interestingly the treatment we just
didn't see a lot of suppression for this
bluegrass and so again it depends
a lot on cultivar I think and so this is
when I talk about these models for golf
turf we do see cultivar effects but
nowhere near what we see with the
bluegrass and so you know this cultivar
doesn't seem to respond as well to the
root absorb products the trimmer and the
cut list but it did so we didn't see
good results from the foliar products
the Primo Max and the ANU and so it's
just kind of interesting some of those
results so then you know the field the
sports turf is a little bit interesting
so yeah okay good rye grass that was the
one the other one was go back to that
the concoctions that different mixes
because I know in golf you talk a lot
about those combinations and so in those
cases on sports turf where you're not
sure what variety you've got I mean you
one way of determining is do you
normally have a hard time getting that
field to wake up in the spring like we
do at Cornell we've got a a soccer field
that we cut in an inch and a quarter
it's sod type midnight tight compact
America tight varieties produced on the
sod farm we we have had some good
success oddly enough with trim it but we
went out at a pretty pretty good rate I
think we were close into the 30 ounce
range for that what do you think about
the combination products yeah how many
products work fine they and so we're
we're seeing you know interestingly
again some sometimes these data aren't
always the most clear things in the
world especially in the bluegrass is
where the legacy seemed to do really
well but then musketeer which is legacy
Plus packages all which is generally a
product that really couldn't shut down
growth we didn't have as good of
suppression out and so those are premix
formulations and so maybe how they've
formulated that is didn't provide the
same level of result for just miss
cultivar of bluegrass the rye grasses we
look at them they respond a much more
consistently we see a really nice
suppression and then it kind of wore off
and the thing will notice for our models
in Nebraska is that we've never
this big growth surged afterwards and
the reason that we think is in Nebraska
summer it's miserably hot and humid in
the right grass just doesn't have the
juice to really have that big rebound
and so after the suppression wore off
things were kind of done for that
product so and then here's kind of like
a trim it and you notice again here is
we have the low rate versus the higher
rates and we'll sell see these same bill
rates have more suppression or less
suppression high rates have more a lot
more suppression but they all kind of
wear off at the same time and so really
thinking about you know what your
application rate is doing is the more
important thing to to be considering and
if you need to start getting more
suppression if things are really like I
got a shutdown and I don't care what
that grass looks like but you can't go
to higher rate because the label doesn't
allow you to well then start adding
different PGR zones or start tightening
your intervals so you're applying more
frequently which results in the PG are
being applied more frequently than the
plant can actually break it down and so
over time you start to simulate a higher
rate by applying more and more
frequently bill risk of injury let's I
want to start wrapping this up a rib
injury you know let's start with that I
know in the golf world you talk about
the risk of injury greater when we're
growing slower we're certainly growing
slower a lot of us have rye that grows
more rapidly in with the bluegrass as
well so what kind of what kind of injury
should we be bracing ourselves for it
really depends so look at this a good
picture here in the bottom this grass is
the yellow line
it has 95 percent growth suppression
which is all the growth that occurs from
gibberellin production so I have zero
gibberellin being made there's no sigh
long Gatien the cells are not growing
and any discoloration that you see there
is not the actual discoloration of the
grass it is from the mower mowing the
tips and fraying those tips and we're
seeing this brown hue on top as a result
of that
so what it shows is that our traffic
tolerance is is greatly diminished
because that grass can't recover and and
mow off and you know the damaged tissue
but and we don't have Chinese traffic on
it there's no real damage especially if
for mowing to the 1/3 rule so if I'm
mowing this at the 1/3 rule which would
be maybe every two weeks or more I'm not
gonna have any of this discoloration
because I'm not going to be constantly
mowing those tips every two days when
they're not growing so that's the bigger
takeaway here is your growth rate needs
to match what what your traffic levels
are if you even have a lot more traffic
you mean more nitrogen to stimulate more
growth to recover from that where if all
the sudden we've eliminated that traffic
and we really dialed our mowing back we
can handle 95% clipping the old
suppression and still look okay because
we don't need to grow any grass and
those leaves can just sit there and make
sugar gonna be happy and make roots and
everything can be okay so here's here's
my last question I'm gonna let you go
cuz I'm sure Sam's around I'm always
happy to see him and see if he's around
if I say I want to start doing growth
regulators am I married to it one of the
things your work shows is yeah you get
suppression but if you don't maintain
your intervals which you know gets to be
a hassle if you can't reliably know when
you can work how how would you factor in
listen if you're gonna do this you got
to keep doing it is if you stop now you
got more problems so talk to talk me
through no I'm worried about rebound if
I can't get back out there so that
rebound is what happens after you apply
the product and after it wears off all
the sugars and all the things that were
blocked and now I'll go forward in the
grass gross so if you take those same
concepts the temperature and growing
degree days predict how long these
products last and if rate predicts how
much suppression I'm getting well you
can do is if you want to go off the PG
ARS and go back to normal you just start
up reapplying at the intervals that are
recommended which are in our green
keeper app and those are freely
available for sports turf users too
that's not just a golf app even though
it looks
that way and you just start reducing
your rates back to normal and you reduce
it back to near zero and then by doing
that you can minimize the potential to
have this big growth surge current so if
you're during coma and you're just like
I don't want any growth and you're doing
30 ounces an acre of any PGR and you're
getting 80 90 percent suppression then
you start wearing that down and saying I
need some more growth now well then do
20 ounces are 10 ounces and kind of work
your way back to zero and that will
minimize the risk of the rebound and the
other thing too is if you're trying to
do this in the middle of July and it's
really stressful as it is anyways I got
that rye grass I showed before
it won't rebound it's too stressed out
to do the rebound
and so you can just cut it off and you
probably won't have too many problems
that way either so it isn't like
something where you start and you're
just locked in for the whole season
although I would recommend you know
sports turf managers to try a lower rate
of these products to get a little bit of
suppression because it is gonna increase
that density to increase plant health
qualities so you can reduce fertility
requirements and so being at maybe 2 5
or 10 ounce rate of tronex a pack or a 8
to 10 ounce rate of my new things like
that they're gonna give us a little bit
of suppression we'll see a lot of
benefit from to stay on that all season
long great Carl do we have questions
either for myself or bittle to answer
before we wrap it up
we've got no questions and I think you
guys really covered a lot especially
talking about how you can kind of go
before you see the plant physically
change and how it starts to become more
difficult to to return I thought that
was a big one we addressed today
and you know the PGR is really
understanding how and when you're gonna
be able to use those the species thing
is something we didn't get into last
week but really differentiating between
things like blue grass and tall fescue
and rye grass I think was great for
everybody to hear because that's that's
a deeper discussion but certainly
relevant for a lot of people listening
so I think that's one of those things
and greenkeeper there's 600 PGR models
and they are all specific to that the
product the species and the
so if you decide to use a green keep
wrap and you're going to set up your
course and you had your area as athletic
field type the system knows that's a
field and it's rye grass and when you
put down trim it this is the growing
greeting interval this is how much
suppression we're getting it already
accounts for that information and so all
you have to do is tell the day you
applied and then go your home page it
will automatically keep track that
you're growing entry days for you so you
have to think about it and now we're
releasing this feature where if you said
in primo and trim it and then three days
later you did a new it would start
combining all three of those
applications and telling you how much
suppression are you're getting in total
not just I'm getting twenty percent here
fifteen percent there forty five percent
here I'm even in the golf world now we
just started building models for DMI
fungicides and in Maui we can even
account for how much suppression you're
getting from topic on is all or you know
propiconazole and all those those DM
eyes that potentially have some growth
inhibiting effects that's right because
there are going to be some higher-end
sports operations even Sam base feels it
might have and your bluegrass in them or
Kentucky bluegrass with necrotic wing
spot any of these root borne pathogens
and they're going to use a DMI fungicide
because it's allowed and and it's
effective they're going to get enhanced
suppress enhance grow suppression from
some of those so that's why you know but
we've been really stressing it and I
gotta tell you a big kudos again for
creating Green keeper and I'm really
glad now that we're really directly
talent sports field managers they can
they can use it there's models in there
that are friendly for their use
III think this is going to give us a
better understanding of how to use these
tools and data when you can't get in or
you've got to justify why you're going
into work you got to have data to say
okay here's why I'm doing it smart guy
say this is essential I want to raise
the height so we don't have a field that
looks like a cow pasture when we get
back there in June or July which who
knows yeah instead of just saying I have
to be in there if you have some kind of
a model or something that you can say
look and I have to be there because my
grass is this high and it has to be
mowed at this height or
I have to apply my you know summer patch
because the soils are the right
temperature it's really it's not easier
to get you know an exemption or
justification then well I just do it
because that's what we got to do these
times of the year and they're gonna say
well it's different times of the year so
I'll just deal and I gotta tell you this
is where the golf guys have gone awry
you know they've determined these things
to be essential that I don't think we're
having these kinds of minimal
conversations even when there's not play
you know there's this twitching going on
because they can't do the things that
they normally want to do and I think
it's just we got to be better about
getting the data to justify what we're
doing okay Carl I'll keep rambling or is
there any other questions there is a
question a good question from Jason
Crawford our PGA's PGR is restricted in
New York State on K through 12 grounds
now the only thing I will say is as bill
you're mentioning about exemptions
emergency exemptions there is a way you
can get an emergency exemption for these
K through 12 grounds at school districts
and you know if you can make the case
and I think you you might be able to if
you get some of bills data which is
saying if I can use PG ours I don't have
to come in as frequently and I don't
have to mow as much that could be a way
for for you to justify an emergency
exemption of a pesticide whether or not
that it gets through you know the Dec or
whatever I'm not sure but any other
things with that same line of thinking
is the ingredient models predict when
the PG ours are not in the plant anymore
so if you're closed and you have a model
to tell you you know with pretty good
certainty that there's no products left
that I have to reapply now you have an
entry entry interval that is a little
bit more than just twelve hours you can
say look at this product is having
effect for this money growing degree
days which equates to two weeks so you
know we're gonna be shut and no one's on
the field anyways for two weeks I can
reduce my mowing and then just look at
the product labels because some of them
don't have labels for sports turf so
just check like maybe some of the class
B's the rivers or products like I don't
want to see any off the top of my
I don't know for a fact we just check
the label for a sports turf on there and
if you can get that exemption and it's
on the label then then you'd be okay as
long as you have that exemption and I'll
just add that again the child safe
playing field act for those so listening
in New York and we'll get this on tape
for people who watch it the child safe
playing field back the emergency
exemptions allowed school districts and
school boards to provide exemptions for
pesticide use when it's deemed an
emergency as long as it's not routine
one of the things they've been trying to
get away from is the routine application
of pesticides and school grounds and I
think there is a case to be made Carl
that this might be a nice little thing
with data a IQ that we could put to it
to make a nice little case that if this
was a path you want it to go and you had
competent people to do it and deemed
essential to do it you could do it so
listen we're way past where we normally
are and that's because bill I can talk
to you for 10 days about this thing
especially because we don't have these
conversations about higher cut turf and
sports fields that's why particularly I
wanted to have you on out here and we
can use this information in some of our
lawn care thinking we'll have a webinar
tomorrow bill safe all you out Nebraska
thanks so much for joining us Carl pass
it back to you and say goodbye to
everyone thanks for joining you thanks
for joining us we'll see you next week
at 10 o'clock in the morning yeah next
week same time same way and we'll we'll
post you know if we can get a guess next
week or we come up with another topic
we'll certainly post that out on social
media and or email us so once again
thanks everybody for stopping by and and
hopefully getting some knowledge from
Bill thanks thanks a bunch for coming on
and talking about that you know lots of
honest that you know obviously you got
the 600 models and greenkeeper lots of
clippings collection you know leading to
back surgery so this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu